[Musik]
heute wird das urteil im betonplatten
mord von der visa erwartet drei
tatverdächtige sollen die 19 jährige
andrea k erst zur prostitution gezwungen
und sie dann wie müll in der asse
entsorgt haben
wenn ich mir vorstelle dass man andrea k
mit der 21 kilo schweren betonplatte auf
dem autohof
wir überlegt um mir dann noch für einen
letzten schub zu geben und die entlasse
fällt
das macht ja ich habe sowas brutales in
meinem leben noch nicht erlebt das war
eine kaltblütige hinrichtung da sind
restzweifel aber von einem mord kann man
hier in meinen augen nicht sprechen lang
waren sie das mädchen einmal
kennengelernt haben sie es denn gesehen
an den wochenenden
die frau hat gespielt aber noch so ein
kleines könig hat ein bisschen gespielt
aber komplett alles direkt chinesisch
ist die pizza kartons und die pizza
konnten
[Musik]
das ist seine schwester ich will noch
nicht realisieren so das ist haut mit
das ist wirklich hart angeklagt sind
drei personen zwei männer und eine frau
man weiß bislang immer noch nicht wer
von diesem 3 andrea getötet hat was
erhoffen sie sich jetzt für einen
vorteil was erwarten sie auch
[Musik]
die
so
entscheiden
flash
nein
bei bleiben
die 10
erleben
michelle
[Musik]